Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history and our ongoing world cup themed epic and dominic today we are arriving in one of the great powerhouses of the world cup mexico and mexico city's estadio azteca one of only two stadiums to have hosted the World Cup final twice. Guy, Tom, that's a good footballing fact from you. Did you know that? You don't normally come out with these stadium facts on this podcast.
感谢您收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》以及我们持续进行的世界杯主题特辑。多米尼克，今天我们来到世界杯的一大重镇——墨西哥，以及墨西哥城的阿兹特克体育场，这是仅有的两座曾两度举办世界杯决赛的体育场之一。盖伊，汤姆，你这个足球冷知识挺不错的。你知道这个吗？你平时在这个播客里可不怎么说这种体育场的冷知识。
Stadium facts, I've got it. And the other one is Rio de Janeiro's Maracana. Maracana, yeah. I hope I pronounced that right. Maracana. Maracana. I saw the squiggle in the wrong place. I briefly thought it was the Macarena, actually.
体育场的冷知识，我知道。另一个是里约热内卢的马拉卡纳。马拉卡纳，对。希望我没发错音。马拉卡纳。马拉卡纳。我把那个符号看错位置了。其实我刚才短暂地以为那是玛卡丽娜（Macarena）。
The Macarena. I wish you said the Macarena. Would have been even better. Anyway, so what have you got for us that is Mexican-themed? What aspect of Mexican history? We're in the autumn. It's very unusual to have an autumn World Cup. And in the autumn, in non-Mexican countries, you think of Mexico in the autumn,
玛卡丽娜。我真希望你说的是玛卡丽娜。那样会更好。不管怎样，你给我们准备了什么具有墨西哥特色的内容？墨西哥历史的哪个方面？现在是秋天。秋季举办世界杯是非常罕见的。而在秋天，在非墨西哥国家的人看来，一想到秋天的墨西哥，
and I think you think of one thing above all, which is the Day of the Dead. Do you think of mexico in the autumn and i think you think of one thing above all which is the day of the dead do you think of the day of the dead tom yes i do well those people who haven't been to mexico and don't know anything about the day of the dead may well remember the scene at the beginning of the james bond film specter have you seen this from 2015 tom where um the opening sequence uh oh, vaguely, yes, vaguely. And he jumps around, doesn't he? There's a big square and he jumps off buildings and things. Right. Well, James Bond always jumps around, Tom, I think it's fair to say.
我想你首先会想到一件事，那就是亡灵节。你会想到秋天的墨西哥，我想你首先会想到一件事，那就是亡灵节。你会想到亡灵节吗，汤姆？是的，我确实会。好吧，那些没去过墨西哥、对亡灵节一无所知的人，很可能会记得詹姆斯·邦德电影《幽灵党》开头的那个场景。你见过这个吗，汤姆，2015年的那部？就是那个开场镜头，呃……哦，隐约记得，是的，隐约记得。他到处乱跳，对吧？有一个很大的广场，他从建筑物上跳下来之类的。没错。好吧，詹姆斯·邦德总是到处乱跳，汤姆，我觉得可以这么说。
So for those people who don't know, there's a long tracking shot through the procession, great parades and floats, people dressed as all kinds of sort of skeletons and demons and things. James Bond, it turns out, is wearing this fantastic skeleton costume with a top hat and a suit. Extraordinary costume.
所以对于那些不知道的人来说，镜头有一个长长的跟踪镜头，穿过游行队伍、盛大的阅兵和花车，人们打扮成各种各样的骷髅、恶魔之类的东西。结果证明，詹姆斯·邦德穿着这套极其惊艳的骷髅服，戴着高顶礼帽，穿着西装。非同寻常的服装。
And it's this incredibly sumptuous, exotic scene, clearly designed to be a quintessentially Mexican moment. It's very typical of you, Dominic, though, that you would go for James Bond when there's a much more obvious mainstream film, recent film that's featured around the Dead of the Dead, which is the Pixar film Coco.
这是一个极其华丽、异国情调的场景，显然旨在成为一个极具墨西哥特色的时刻。不过多米尼克，这非常符合你的风格，当有一个更明显、更大众化的近期电影——同样以亡灵节为主题的皮克斯电影《寻梦环游记》（Coco）时，你却偏偏挑了詹姆斯·邦德。
I've never seen it, Tom. I've never seen it. Okay, so I really hate Pixar films. They kind of came in when my children were young, and so I just had to watch them over and over again, and so I have a deep, deep hatred for them. Crikey, you don don't often hear that and i kind of boycott them as a matter of principle and then i was on we've done it saturday review it's a kind of radio 4 review program and i saw that i had to do this pixar film coco and it was about the day of the
我从来没看过，汤姆。我从来没看过。好吧，所以我真的很讨厌皮克斯电影。它们大约是在我孩子还小的时候出现的，所以我不得不一遍又一遍地看，因此我对它们有着深深的、深刻的恨意。天哪，你可不常听到这种说法。而且我出于原则问题抵制它们。然后我在《星期六评论》（Saturday Review）上——这是一个类似BBC第四台的评论节目——看到我必须评论这部皮克斯电影《寻梦环游记》，它讲的是亡灵节的故事。我坐下来，绝对下定决心要讨厌它、鄙视它。但到了最后，我泪流满面。这是一部绝对精彩、极其煽情的电影。这就是皮克斯的天才之处。确实如此。我很讨厌它，但我当时……而这直接切入了神话的核心，讲的是人们真正死去、又死而复生之类的事情。所以……所以我猜皮克斯电影所借用的，和邦德电影《幽灵党》所借用的是完全一样的东西，也就是这种将病态感和异国情调融为一体的想法。所以亡灵节这个概念是一个绝对具有墨西哥标志性的东西，它表达了墨西哥灵魂中的某种东西。每当你读到对它的任何描述，它都跃然纸上。所以我谷歌了一下“亡灵节”。
dead and i sat down absolutely determined to hate and despise it by the end i was in floods it's an absolutely brilliant and brilliantly manipulative film that's the genius of pixar it is i hated it i was but i was and that that kind of plunges into the heart of the myth and it's about people actually dying coming back from the dead all that kind of stuff so so i assume what the pixar film is playing on is exactly the same thing that the bond film, Spectre, is playing on, which is this idea of a sort of morbidity and an exoticism wrapped into one. So that idea of the Day of the Dead is something absolutely emblematically Mexican and is expressing something in the Mexican soul. Whenever you read any description of it, it's right there. So I Google Day of the Dead.
跳出来的第一批结果之一就是猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）。猫途鹰说这是一个有4000年历史的传统，每年11月1日和2日在墨西哥庆祝。我读了《卫报》。《卫报》有一篇专题报道——我知道这是一份你非常放在心上的报纸，汤姆。那肯定是真的，对吧。《卫报》说亡灵节——明确表示亡灵节可以追溯到阿兹特克时期。好吧，但是难道没有这样一种
One of the first things that comes up is TripAdvisor. TripAdvisor says it's a 4,000-year-old tradition celebrated in Mexico on the 1st and 2nd of November every year. I read The Guardian. The Guardian has a feature. I know a newspaper very close to your heart, Tom. Must be true, yeah. The Guardian says the Day of the Dead, explicitly says the Day of the Dead dates back to the Aztec period. Okay, but might there not be an
另类的观点：它其实是一个基督教节日，汤姆？不要预先剧透这个播客的主题！抱歉。人们会想到克吕尼的圣奥迪洛（Saint Odilo of Cluny）。所以，我们一开始谈论的那件事——詹姆斯·邦德的场景、墨西哥城的游行、花车、服装，所有这一切最大的问题在于，根本没有这样的游行——或者至少在电影拍摄时，根本没有这样的游行。这完全是一个……我的意思是，这是电影制片人发明的经典“传统”。所以根本没有亡灵节游行。
alternative perspective that it's a christian festival tom do not anticipate the theme of this podcast sorry i'm one thinks of saint adilo of cluny so that thing that we that i talked about at the beginning the james bond scene the parade in mexico city the floats the costumes the great problem with all this is that there is no such, or certainly when the film was made, there was no such parade. It was a complete, I mean, this was the classic invented tradition, invented by the filmmakers. So there's no Day of the Dead parade.
而且在我们在非墨西哥人看来，关于亡灵节的几乎所有事情都是错的。甚至连它的名字也是如此，它被称为“Dia de Muertos”，但从语法上讲，它应该是“Dia de los Muertos”。所以它在语法上有点处于灰色地带。日期是有争议的。通常它是在11月1日和2日庆祝的，
And everything about the Day of the Dead in our sort of non-Mexican imagination, almost everything about it is wrong. So even the name of it, so it's called Dia de Muertos, but grammatically it should be Dia de los Muertos. So it's kind of occupies a gray area there. The date is contested. So usually it's celebrated on the 1st and 2nd of November,
但也可能提前一两天。至于为什么会这样，我们一会儿会讨论。它其实有着历史根源。现在谈到这个传统，每当你阅读任何相关资料时，他们都会告诉你，这是一个为了纪念逝者的节日，是墨西哥人的一种习俗。它表达了他们对死亡的某种极度痴迷。这可以追溯到阿兹特克人进行活人献祭等等。
but it could be a day or two earlier. And the reason it could be, we'll get into. It's sort of rooted in history. Now the tradition, so when you read anything about it, they will tell you that this is a holiday to honor the dead, that the Mexicans do. It expresses something very deep about their obsession with death. And this goes back to the Aztecs sacrificing people and all this.
这就是那个萌芽中的想法。这正是那个萌芽中的想法，没错。他们会纪念逝者。他们会搭建祭坛。你会在家里搭建一个名为“ofrenda”的祭坛，摆上你死去的亲人最喜欢的食物和饮料。你会带着这些东西作为礼物，对墓地进行一次浩浩荡荡的远征；你会把礼物送给你的朋友，你会送他们一种叫做“calaveras”的东西，也就是糖骷髅；
That's the Incoate idea. This is the Incoate idea, exactly. That they will honor them. They will build altars. You'll build an altar in your home called an ofrenda with the favorite foods and the drinks of your dead loved ones. You will make a huge expedition to the graveyard with these things as gifts uh you will give gifts to your friends you'll give them things called calaveras which are candy sugar skulls you
你会和亲朋好友分享一种叫做“pan de muerto”（亡灵面包）的特殊面包，你还会为活着的人写一些恶搞的墓志铭。所以你会写一些这种开玩笑的诗句，它们被称为“calaveras literarias”，也就是文学骷髅诗。这个节日的另一个方面是花。你会到处看到花，橙色的万寿菊，它们被认为是死亡的象征。
will share a special bread called the panda muerto with your friends and family and you will write sort of mock epitaphs for for for people who alive. So you'll write these sort of jokey verses, and they're called calaveras literarias, so literary calaveras. So the other aspect of this is flowers. So you see the flowers everywhere, orange marigolds, which are meant to be the sort of symbol of death.
在墨西哥，它们被称为“cempasúchil”，这个词源自纳瓦特尔语，意思是“二十朵花”，被称为亡灵之花。所以这又一次与阿兹特克人的过去联系在了一起。事实上，关于这些万寿菊——你熟悉16世纪的《佛罗伦萨抄本》（Florentine Codex）吗？是的，我们和卡米拉·唐桑特（Camilla Townsend）聊过这个。没错，这个伟大的来源，这本由方济各会修士在16世纪中期——也就是西班牙征服之后——撰写的开创性民族志著作。他在书中谈到了梅西卡人（Messica）——也就是我们所说的阿兹特克人——的生活，他说他们非常喜爱这些花，并且
They're called in Mexico, sempa su chil, which comes from the Nahuatl word which means 20 flowers and it's called the flower of the dead so again that's sort of linked back to the the aztec past and in fact those marigolds are you familiar with the florentine codex of the 16th century yes we talked about it with uh camilla tanzant exactly so this great source this pioneering work of ethnography by franciscan friar in the in the mid 16th century so after the spanish conquest and he's talking about life among the the messica the aztecs as we would call them and he says they love these flowers and they
在他们的宗教仪式中使用这些花。它们是黄色的，很漂亮，气味非常……你知道的，诸如此类，因为他是为欧洲读者写这本书的。当然，你可以理解为什么人们会认为其中一些内容是有历史根源的。而且，为了给不太熟悉这一习俗的人讲几个细节——我想我们的美国听众对这一切的熟悉程度，应该会比英国或澳大利亚的听众高得多，因为在英国，墨西哥文化、墨西哥食物以及诸如此类的东西，根本没有这种地位。
use these flowers in their religious rituals they're yellow they they're beautiful they smell very you know all this because he's writing about this for a european audience there's a sure you can sort of see why people would think some of this is is rooted in history and um and just to go into a couple of the details for people who are not familiar so our american listeners i would imagine will be much more familiar with this all this than our british ones or our australian ones because of course in britain mexican culture and Mexican food and all that sort of thing doesn't have anything like this.
不过，多米尼克，还有一点，我的意思是，并非要抢话，但也因为我们不是一个天主教国家。完全正确。所以确信我们很快就会谈到这一维度中的天主教因素。让我们深入探讨几个特定的元素，我们的美国听众，以及如果有墨西哥听众的话，他们会立刻认出这些元素。我刚才提到了面包。
But also, Dominic, also, I mean, not to preempt, but also we're not a Catholic country. Exactly. So I'm sure we'll come to the Catholic dimension of this fairly soon. So let's just dig into a couple of particular elements to this that our American, and indeed if we have any Mexican listeners, that they will immediately recognise. So I mentioned bread.
这是一种甜面包，pan de muerto（亡灵面包），一种“pan dulce”（甜面包）。它的形状像一个小圆面包，上面装饰着几乎像是骨头的东西，你知道的，用面团做成的骨头。面包顶部是圆圆的，有些人说这代表坟墓，诸如此类。有时候人们说这些骨头代表坟墓……诸如此类，有时候人们说这些骨头代表死者的骨头。所以从本质上讲，英语世界与之对应的就是万圣节。好吧，我们会谈到这一点，这和万圣节有什么关系？它们之间有什么联系吗？我想你比我更了解万圣节，所以你可以……我要问你关于万圣节的事。所以你有面包——我的意思是，在不列颠群岛，我们没有万圣节面包，对吧？没有。
So a sweet, it's a kind of sweet bread, pan de muerto, a kind of pan dulce. And it's shaped like a bun and it's decorated with kind of almost like bones, you know, sort of pastry bones. There's a sort of rounded top of the bread and some people say it's like a grave, all of this kind of stuff. Sometimes the people say the bones are meant grave um all of this kind of stuff sometimes the people say the bones are meant to be the bones of the dead person so essentially i mean the um in the english-speaking world's equivalent is halloween well we will come to this what's it
而且，确实有一个经常被重复的故事——如果你谷歌一下，如果你查看任何历史网站，而不仅仅是普通的旅游网站，他们都会说：嗯，这可以追溯到阿兹特克人的人祭传统。所以这是某个网站上的说法。
got to do with halloween is the some kind of link i think you know more much more about halloween than i do so you will be able to i'm going to ask you about halloween so you've got the bread i mean we don't have a halloween bread do we in the british isles no um and indeed there is this frequently repeated story again if you google it if you look at any kind of i'm talking about history websites not just sort of generic travel websites they will say well this dates back to the aztec tradition of human sacrifice um so this is from one website. It says, a maiden was offered to the gods. They placed a still beating heart in a pot with amaranth,
它说，曾有一个少女被献给神明。他们把一颗还在跳动的心脏放在一个装有苋菜籽的罐子里，
and they had to bite it as a symbol of gratitude. And the story goes, and you can sort of see the implausibility of this, that the conquistadors, in their enlightened, kindly ways, disgusted with the cannibalism and the sacrificial nature of Aztec religion, they compelled the Mexicans to replace the heart that they would be biting with a bun. And that's the origins of the bun.
他们必须咬它一口作为感恩的象征。故事是这样的——你也能看出这有多么不合情理——征服者以他们开明、仁慈的方式，对阿兹特克宗教的食人风俗和献祭本质感到厌恶，于是他们强迫墨西哥人用一个小圆面包来代替他们原本要咬的心脏。这就是面包的起源。
Tom, I can see you scoffing. You clearly are a revisionist and and and bred history terms you're clearly a well no it's just that it is it is a very popular theme that particularly on the internet yeah that christian festivals have their origins in pagan antecedents and we talked about that with ron hutton didn't we yeah we did it in our episode on christmas the idea that basically christian festivals are attempts to kind of dress up in christian dressing ancient pagan rituals yes this is a very popular theme and almost invariably rubbish well the mexican government the official mexican government website says that uh this is disagrees with you.
汤姆，我看得出你在嗤之以鼻。你显然是个修正主义者，在面包历史的定义上，你显然是个……哦，不，只是这确实是一个非常受欢迎的主题，尤其是在互联网上，即基督教节日源自异教的前身。我们在和罗恩·赫顿（Ron Hutton）的节目中讨论过这个，对吧？是的，我们在关于圣诞节的那期节目中讨论过。这种观点认为，基督教节日基本上就是试图用基督教的外衣来包装古老的异教仪式。是的，这是一个非常受欢迎的主题，但几乎无一例外都是垃圾。好吧，墨西哥政府，墨西哥官方政府网站说，这……不同意你的观点。
The official government Mexican website says this definitely is related to pre-conquest indigenous traditions. The National Institute of Indigenous People in Mexico also says, oh no, this is absolutely indigenous tradition. It's pre-Hispanic, all this kind of thing. So you've got the bread. And then the other element is the sugar the sugar skulls the calaveras so i i googled them for their for their origins one of the first things that came up was the website of top historian martha stewart the american cook yes and her website says cooking jailbird right correct and her website says, unequivocally, the sugar skull tradition can be traced back over 3,000 years ago.
墨西哥官方政府网站说，这绝对与前西班牙时期的本土传统有关。墨西哥国家原住民研究所也表示：“哦，不，这绝对是本土传统。它是前西班牙时期的，诸如此类。”所以你有面包。然后另一个元素是糖，糖骷髅，也就是calaveras。我谷歌了一下它们的起源，跳出来的第一批结果之一就是顶级大厨、美国美食家玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）的网站。
So people were Aztecs 3,000 years ago. I mean, the Aztecs didn't actually exist 3,000 years ago, but there you go, that they were making sugar skulls and exchanging them on the Day of the Dead. And, in fact, the more you Google, the more different. So some people say, well, actually, you know what? It's not actually Aztec. It a it's a mayan tradition or toltec you know the the the origins go right exactly further and further but the point the sort of the underlying point
她的网站说，烹饪惯犯对吧？没错。她的网站明确表示，糖骷髅的传统可以追溯到3000多年前。
of all this is that this is a dark and a is ultimately what we have now in coco inspector in mexican households is a is a, sanitized, 21st century version of a dark and ancient ritual that is bound up with human sacrifice and that expresses something about the Mexican soul, a kind of intense morbidity. The essence. Yeah, an intense morbidity. And actually, it also expresses something about Mexican political
所以3000年前的人就是阿兹特克人了。我的意思是，3000年前阿兹特克人根本不存在，但不管怎样，他们当时就在制作糖骷髅并在亡灵节这天交换它们。事实上，你谷歌得越多，差异就越大。有些人会说，好吧，其实你知道吗？这其实不是阿兹特克的，这是玛雅传统或托尔特克传统……你知道，它的起源可以追溯得更早、更远。但重点是……所有这一切背后的潜台词是，这是一种黑暗的仪式，我们在《寻梦环游记》、 《幽灵党》以及墨西哥家庭中所看到的，最终是这种黑暗而古老仪式的21世纪消毒版。它与活人献祭紧密相连，表达了墨西哥灵魂中的某种东西，一种强烈的病态感。本质。是的，一种强烈的病态感。事实上，它也表达了墨西哥政治
and cultural identity that the post-conquest Catholicism and Europeanization is merely a veneer. And when you scratch that away, you get to the ancient inheritance beneath. Yeah, so it's like the Virgin of Guadalupe being actually a kind of ancient goddess or whatever. Exactly so. So that's what, 1530s? I think the – exactly. And of course, Tom, you know what I'm going to say. I'm with you.
和文化认同中的某种东西：征服后的天主教和欧洲化仅仅只是一层表象。当你剥开这层表象，就能触及底层的古老传承。是的，这就好比瓜达卢佩圣母实际上是一个古老女神之类的。完全正确。所以那是1530年代吗？我想——完全是。当然，汤姆，你知道我要说什么。我和你站在同一边。
I think all this is complete and utter nonsense. Let's take those two foodstuffs that are associated. The bread and the skulls. The bread and the skulls. So start with the skulls. The great issue with this is that people weren't making sweets out of sugar before the spanish conquest so it's complete nonsense most actual food historians think that these sugar
我认为这一切完全是无稽之谈。让我们来看看与之相关的两种食品：面包和骷髅。面包和骷髅。先从骷髅开始。这里最大的问题在于，在西班牙征服之前，人们根本不用糖来制作糖果。所以这完全是无稽之谈。大多数真正的美食历史学家认为，这些糖骷髅起源于18世纪——当时墨西哥是新西班牙，西班牙人擅长用面包和杏仁膏塑造各种形状。他们太喜欢这么做了，爱不释手。
skulls originate in the 18th century when mexico was new spain the the spanish were whizzes molding things out of bread and marzipan they loved doing it they loved it they loved it well why wouldn't you do you like i would i mean i i've tom i've had breakfast at your house and i wouldn't describe you as a you're not one of life's you're not rick stein is that fair to say i think that would be fair to say but then again i've never actually tried to make a a skull out of marzipan maybe i'd be brilliant at it yeah you know there's always been a bit of a sort of and all the time i've known you there's a kind of quest there's a sense of a ring yes a yearning to express yeah my sense of the skull beneath the skin through the medium of cookery
好吧，你为什么不这么做呢？你喜欢吗？我的意思是……汤姆，我在你家吃过早饭，我绝不会形容你是个……你可不是那种生活中的……你可不是里克·斯坦（Rick Stein），这样说公平吗？我觉得这挺公平的。不过话说回来，我其实从来没试过用杏仁膏做一个骷髅头，也许我很擅长呢。是的，你知道，我认识你这么久以来，你身上一直有一种追求……有一种渴望，想要通过烹饪这种媒介，表达我对皮囊之下的骷髅的感知。
this is your equivalent of alexander the great's pothos. It is. His yearning, his dream of something beyond. It is. That you as a patissier go... Yes. It's a dream that one day I will follow. But not yet. I think my stiff, uptight Anglo-Saxon nature has prevented me from following that dream. Okay, what about baking?
这简直就是你版本的亚历山大大帝的“渴望”（pothos）。确实如此。他对超越之境的渴望和梦想。确实如此。你作为一个糕点师……是的。这是一个梦想，总有一天我会去追求。但还不是时候。我想我那种死板、紧绷的盎格鲁-萨克逊天性阻止我去追逐这个梦想。好吧，那烘焙呢？
Like baking more generally, bread. Let's move on to the bread. Okay. Do you ever make bread? No. that's one thing i would never do okay well it gets that as a matter of principle just close your ears to the next section because it'll be of no interest to you no i'm interested in what other people do but i don't want to do it so all that stuff under the lockdown people baking bread yeah i despise that oh that's hard that's to say do not brave bread no okay right well fine
比如更广泛的烘焙，做面包。我们换到面包。好吧。你烤过面包吗？从不。那是绝对一件我永远不会做的事。好吧，既然你出于原则问题，那就对下一节内容闭起耳朵吧，因为它对你毫无吸引力。不，我对别人做什么感兴趣，但我自己不想做。所以封锁期间大家都在烤面包的那股风潮……是的，我对此鄙视至极。哦，太苛刻了。怎么能说“别烤面包”呢？不，好吧，fine。
no she did the garden okay what do you do uh i was i think i was translating satonius well that says it all doesn't it i mean that's that's my idea of fun so so let's talk about bread so the panda muerto very important part of the Mexican Day of the Dead tradition. The ingredients of that bread are wheat, cane sugar, cow's milk, butter, eggs, and a sort of orange zest or something. And these things, basically, none of these things were present in. Oh, you and your bracing skepticism. So I have a quote here from Elsa Malbido from the Institute of Anthropology in Mexico City. And she said, I read i read this tom and thought of you she said if we think the day of the dead is a tradition of pre-hispanic origin that means we do
没有，她去整花园了。那你做什么？呃……我当时在翻译苏埃托尼奥斯（Suetonius）。这真是一言难尽，对吧？这就是我对快乐的定义。所以，我们来谈谈面包吧。Pan de muerto（亡灵面包），墨西哥亡灵节传统中非常重要的一部分。这种面包的成分是小麦、蔗糖、牛奶、黄油、鸡蛋，以及一些橙皮屑之类。而这些东西，基本上……没有一样是原本存在的……哦，你和你那令人振奋的怀疑论啊。所以我这里有一段来自墨西哥城人类学研究所的埃尔萨·马尔比多（Elsa Malbido）的话。她说——我读到这段话时想到了你——她说：“如果我们认为亡灵节是一个具有前西班牙时期起源的传统，那就意味着我们什么也不懂，因为它实际上带有极深的罗马色彩。”你一定对此感到非常兴奋吧，拉丁美洲万岁！
not understand anything since it is deeply roman you must be very excited by that go latin america so what's the story what's the real story um behind it so as you will know tom i imagine in medieval europe there was a tradition of eating special bread anyway on all saints day they would call it panda animus bread of souls and they would sometimes make it in the shape of people and all saints day is the first of november right so you've basically got all hallows eve is that right that's that's halloween that's halloween um all saints day or all hallows yeah and then all souls and all souls day was popularized by uh saint adilo of cluny right in the 10th century and it's the idea that um it's obviously the saints are in heaven but everyone else is in
那么背后的故事是什么？真正的故事是什么？正如你所知，汤姆，我想在中世纪欧洲，无论如何都有在诸圣节（All Saints' Day）吃特制面包的传统。他们会称之为“panis animus”，也就是灵魂面包，有时他们会把它做成人的形状。诸圣节是11月1日，对吧？所以基本上万圣节前夜（All Hallows' Eve）就是……对，那是万圣节。那是万圣节。万圣节前夜或万圣节之夜……然后是诸灵节（All Souls' Day）。诸灵节是在10世纪由克吕尼的圣奥迪洛（Saint Odilo of Cluny）推广开来的。它的理念是……当然圣徒们在天堂，但其他人都在
purgatory yeah so it's a way of of focusing on them and their their purgative sufferings well i know you like a purgative suffering love it and you would therefore be at one with the great american historian stanley brands who is the world expert tom on, on the Day of the Dead. And his excellent book, which I commend to the listeners, Skulls to the Living, Bread to the Dead. Excellent title. That's a fabulous title. It's a very good title. So he's gone through all this, and he basically says,
炼狱里。所以这是一种关注他们及其炼狱苦难的方式。我知道你喜欢炼狱般的苦难。我太爱了。因此，你一定会赞同伟大的美国历史学家斯坦利·布兰兹（Stanley Brandes）的观点。他是世界级的汤姆……关于亡灵节的专家。他那本出色的书——我向听众大力推荐——《献给生者的骷髅，献给死者的面包》（Skulls to the Living, Bread to the Dead）。好书名。这名字太棒了。这名字确实很好。所以他研究了所有这些，他基本上指出：
in Iberia, in Spain, in the 1500s, All Souls Day was a massive, massive deal. So there would be a sort of catafalque in a church. There would be all sorts of candles. There would be shed loads of bread. People would bring in all this bread. With orange zest? With all this.
在1500年代的伊比利亚半岛、西班牙，诸灵节是一件极其、极其重大隆重的事。教会里会搭起灵柩台。会有各种各样的蜡烛。会有海量的面包。人们会带进所有的这些面包。加了橙皮屑的？带了所有这些。
Well, of course, once you've got the Columbian Exchange, you are going to have a lot more spiced, scented stuff. And of course, sugar. Stuff. Yeah, stuff that's the technical you know when you work in the kitchen tom as i often am under enormous pressure you don't have time to get me that stuff the techno bubble yeah get me a handful of stuff so he's gone through all the sort of records of guilds and things in places like barcelona mad, places that have all these records. And he has found, for example, the first mention that he can find of the Day of the Dead, Dia de los Muertos, in Catalan, comes from 1671.
当然，一旦有了哥伦布大交换（Columbian Exchange），你就会拥有更多香料味、芳香味的东西。当然还有糖。各种东西。是的，“各种东西”——你知道的，当你在厨房工作时，汤姆，正如我经常在巨大压力下做的那样，你没有时间去拿那些……那些技术性的……呃，给我拿一把“各种东西”来。所以他查阅了巴塞罗那、马德里等地的各种行会和其他机构的记录——这些地方保存了所有这些记录。他发现，例如，他所能找到的关于加泰罗尼亚语中的亡灵节（Dia de los Muertos）的最早记载可以追溯到1671年。
And it's talking about people exchanging bread, people exchanging all this sort of stuff. So in other words, that's not happening in Mexico, that's happening in Spain. And you would think, okay, well, they must have obviously shipped that tradition over to Mexico, and then it went through various sort of evolutions and all this. But no, actually.
上面谈到人们互换面包，人们互换所有这些东西。换句话说，这并非发生在墨西哥，而是发生在西班牙。你可能会想，好吧，他们肯定把这个传统运到了墨西哥，然后它经历了各种演变，诸如此类。但其实并不是。
Wow, it's more complicated than that. It is much more complicated and much more surprising. So I think we should take a quick break. And then when we come back, Tom, we will be in the world of the 20th century, the Mexican Revolution, Graham Greene, and an attempt to replace shockingly father christmas brilliant don't go away i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
哇，这比想象的要复杂。情况要复杂得多，也惊讶得多。我想我们应该休息一下。等我们回来后，汤姆，我们将进入20世纪的世界，走进墨西哥革命、格雷厄姆·格林（Graham Greene），以及一场试图取代……震惊世人的圣诞老人的行动。太棒了，不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Bienvenido we are talking the day of the dead and Dominic, in the first part, you set up this image of the day of the dead as an ancient pre-Columban tradition going back 2,000 years, 3,000 years, 6,000 years, 10,000 years, whatever. But I had always thought that it was essentially kind of introduced by the Catholics catholics uh by the spanish um when they arrived in mexico but the bombshell that you let off just before the the break was the possibility it may be even more recent than that yeah so it's a slightly misleading bombshell if bombshells can be misleading because i think um because i think what is certainly true is that when Mexico becomes, as it were, Christianized in the 16th century, obviously the Spanish import all their traditions, their calendar and so on.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来，我们正在聊亡灵节。多米尼克，在第一部分中，你为我们描绘了亡灵节是一个古老的前哥伦布时期传统，可以追溯到2000年、3000年、6000年、10000年前，诸如此类。但我一直以为它本质上是天主教徒——天主教徒、西班牙人在抵达墨西哥时引入的。不过你在中场休息前投下的重磅炸弹是，它可能比那还要更近？
And there is a kind of, those traditions do get kind of dyed inevitably by the indigenous traditions as well. They absolutely, they absolutely do. And that's actually the, you know, you're talking about the sort of in-cate sort of sense that you have if you're an outsider of Mexico and its cultural identity and its traditions. And that's exactly how most of us think of it, isn't it? It's this sort of syncretic fusion of sort of pre-Columbian survivals and then this's a veneer, but I would say it's a deeply Catholic country now. Yeah. But that it's died, it's tinged with, inevitably, with the culture of the land in which it's set. Let's just go into that a little bit. So the Day of the Dead, the All Souls Day, those traditions that in Europe are sort of split over three days, depending where you are, I guess, aren't they? Because we, that's All Hallows' Eve, all Souls' Day, all Saints' Day, I can't remember the correct order, you'll know. All Saints' first. Yeah.
是的，这是一个略带误导性的重磅炸弹——如果重磅炸弹也能被误导的话——因为我认为……因为我认为可以肯定的是，当墨西哥在16世纪变得“基督教化”时，西班牙人显然输入了他们的所有传统、日历等等。而且毫无疑问，这些传统不可避免地也会染上本土印记。它们绝对、绝对会。事实上，这就好比……你刚才谈到那种局外人对墨西哥及其文化认同和传统的朦胧感觉。而这正是我们大多数人的看法，不是吗？这就是前哥伦布时期幸存元素与……这只是一层表象的这种融合，但我会说它现在是一个深度的天主教国家。是的。但这层表象不可避免地被它所处土地的文化所浸染。让我们稍微深入探讨一下。所以亡灵节、诸灵节——欧洲的这些传统被大致拆分成了三天，取决于你在哪里，对吧？因为我们有万圣节前夜、诸灵节、诸圣节……我记不清正确的顺序了，你肯定知道。诸圣节先。对。
And then all Souls'. So those traditions are clearly, they go over to Mexico, but there's absolutely no sense that they're more meaningful in Mexico than anywhere else. I mean, nobody sort of says, the Mexicans go crazy for this.
然后是诸灵节。所以这些传统显然传到了墨西哥，但完全没有迹象表明它们在墨西哥比在其他任何地方更有意义。我的意思是，没有人会说：墨西哥人为之疯狂。
They can't get enough of it. They put their own spin on it. In terms of mentions of this as the Day of the Dead, the first you get are sort of in 19th century newspapers. In 19th century, they mention that people go in processions to graves. They mention that they have drunken parties. But that's what people are doing in Europe. But this is kind of, so this is the Mexican equivalent of the, you know, it's often said that all traditions in Britain are Victorian. Yeah, it's not true. But there's a kind of enough
他们对它爱不释手，并赋予了它独特的视角。如果说到被称为“亡灵节”的记载，最早出现在19世纪的报纸上。在19世纪，报纸提到人们列队前往墓地，提到他们举行酒会。但这也是欧洲人在做的事情。所以这有点像是——英国所有的传统都是维多利亚时期的，人们常这么说。是的，这虽然不全对，
truth there that it's quite a kind of funny observation yeah basically something as fundamental to mexican identity as the day of the dead is its roots are in the 19th century is that what you're saying but they're not no but in the 19th century people just treat this as another it's just another catholic ritual it's just one of many moments in the catholic calendar there's nothing remarkable about it when it it's mentioned, so historians look at it, they look for mentions in newspapers and so on, they say, oh, yes, this is the Day of the Dead, and people have gone and had a little ceremony.
但也包含足够的真相，算是一个相当有趣的观察。是的，基本上像亡灵节这样对墨西哥认同如此基础的事物，其根源其实在19世纪——你是这个意思吗？但其实也不是。在19世纪，人们只是把它当作又一个……这只是又一个天主教仪式。它只是天主教日历中的众多时刻之一，没有什么特别之处。当它被提及、当历史学家审视它、在报纸等资料中寻找记录时，他们会说：“哦，是的，这就是亡灵节，人们去了并举行了一个小型仪式。”
But there's no sense that this is uniquely Mexican, that it is expressive of something in the national character any more than Easter, Christmas, any know, any other sort of festival. Where the turning point comes, Tom, is in the Mexican Revolution of the 1910s. So the Mexican Revolution is a subject I would love to do on The Rest is History. It is incredibly complicated. Are there lots of acronyms? No, not totally.
但当时绝没有任何迹象表明这是墨西哥独有的，能够表达国民性格的某种特质，这和复活节、圣诞节或任何其他节日没什么两样。真正的转折点发生在1910年代的墨西哥革命，汤姆。墨西哥革命是一个我很想在《历史的其余部分》中讲述的主题。它极其复杂。里面有很多缩写词吗？不，倒也不是完全都是。
There's a lot of characters. In which case I'm willing to do it everybody dies pancho via is in it there's you know zapata great characters the americans pile in there's lots of moustaches there's lots of moustaches if you like a moustache if you like a sombrero and a machine gun in combination yeah i do and this is the revolution for you let's go for it but what you have with the revolution of the 1910s um like it's so much sort of latin american politics in this period you have an intense anti-clericalism um and you have the development afterwards uh by the sort of post-revolutionary regime so you have a succession
里面有很多性格鲜明的人物。既然如此，我很愿意讲！里面每个人都会死，潘乔·维拉（Pancho Villa）也在其中，还有萨帕塔（Zapata），都是了不起的人物。美国人也插手了，里面有数不清的胡子。如果你喜欢胡子、喜欢索布雷罗草帽和机枪的组合……是的，我喜欢。这就是属于你的革命，我们开搞吧！但你在1910年代的革命中所看到的……
of basically you have a succession of generals from the northern province of sonora taking power in mexico and they're often very very aggressively secular because they want to you know they see that as modernity and and they want to take possession of the church's lands i guess they do all of that and what they want to also cultivate they they start to cultivate a new culture a new idea in mexico that's based on sort of indigenous pride so not his Hispanic, not European. And they reject the sort of Europeanization. They see that actually as 19th century as too conservative,
就像这一时期许多拉丁美洲政治一样，你看到了强烈的反教权主义；随后，在革命后政权的发展中——基本上就是有一连串来自北部索诺拉省的将军在墨西哥掌权，他们通常非常、非常激进地主张世俗化，因为他们认为这才是现代性，他们想要收缴教会的土地，我想他们确实做了所有这些。而且他们还想要开始培养一种新文化，一种在墨西哥基于本土骄傲的新理念——不是西班牙的，不是欧洲的。他们排斥欧洲化。他们认为欧洲化其实是19世纪的产物，过于保守，诸如此类。那个嫁给另一个著名画家的著名女画家是谁？弗里达·卡洛（Frida Kahlo）。不，另一个，那个男的。迭戈·里维拉（Diego Rivera）。所以当我身在墨西哥时，那里有迭戈·里维拉创作的惊人壁画。所以当我身在墨西哥时，那里有迭戈·里维拉创作的惊人壁画。
all this sort of thing. What's the famous painter married to the other famous painter? Frida Kahlo. No, the other one, the man. Diego Rivera. So when I was in Mexico, there was this amazing fresco done by Diego Rivera. So when I was in Mexico, there was this amazing fresco done by Diego Rivera.
是的，它把科尔特斯描绘成一个面目可憎的梅毒患者，呈现出带有节状膝盖的绿色，这显然是感染梅毒的特征。我想……那是画在宫殿里的吗？我记不清在哪里了。这是一个非常……梅毒感染了前哥伦布时期健康文化躯体的隐喻。完全正确。绝对是的，汤姆。所以迭戈·里维拉、弗里达·卡洛——当人们从墨西哥境外思考墨西哥艺术时，他们想到的就是1920年代到1940年代左右创作的艺术：那些描绘本土场景的奇妙壁画、明亮的色彩、对欧洲影响的公开排斥以及对本土和……
Yeah. And it showed Cortez as a grotesque syphilitic, kind of green with knobbly knees, which apparently is a sign of someone with syphilis. And I think, is that painted in the palace? I can't remember where it is. It's a very kind of syphilis infecting the healthy body of pre-Columbian culture. Exactly right. Exactly, Tom. So Diego Rivera, Frida Kahlo, that when people think about from outside Mexico, think of Mexican art, they think of that art created between the 1920s and 1940s or so the sort of fantastic murals showing indigenous scenes the bright colors that sort of overt rejection of european influence and the sort of celebration of the indigenous and
不仅是教会，还有上层阶级，对吧？完全正确，绝对如此。所以在其中有两个极其重要的人物。首先是一位革命将军，他在1920年代后半期成为了总统，也就是普utar科·埃利亚斯·卡列斯（Plutarco Elías Calles）。普utar科，普utar科，多棒的名字啊！是的。有趣的是，他的反天主教情绪部分源于他自己的背景，因为他是私生子，他觉得教会曾轻蔑他，教会高层看不起他，这在某种程度上驱使了他。他正是统治了墨西哥71年的制度革命党（PRI）的创始人——虽然他们也会举行选举，但他们每次都赢，对吧？所以这就像日本一样……
the european is is presumably it's not just the church it's also the upper classes exactly right exactly so what you have two two huge figures in this so the first one is um a revolutionary general who becomes president at the end in the second half of the 1920s and that is a guy called plutarcho elias cayes plutarcho plutarcho what a great name that is yeah so he interestingly he his anti-catholicism is partly fueled by his own background because he's illegitimate and he feels that you know the church has scorned him their hierarchy kind of looked down on him and that sort of drives it he is the founder of what's called the institutional revolutionary party that held power for 71 years in mexico you know they had
完全如此，或者确实就像英国。还有他……是的。也许直到……是的，也许这种局面很快就会结束。在下一次选举之前就是考验，对吧？所以，卡列斯大力推行这场反教权运动。他剥夺了教会对教育的控制权，禁止神父参与政治。
elections but they just won them all yeah so it's like japan um exactly or indeed Britain. And he... Yes. Maybe until... Yeah. Maybe that's going to end fairly soon. Before the next election is the test, right? So, Caius really pushes this anti-clerical campaign. He strips the church of its power over education. He bars priests from being involved in politics.
而这正是引发了一场被称为“克里斯特罗战争”（Cristero War）的战争的原因之一。墨西哥农村腹地的基督徒们提出了一个口号：“Viva Cristo Rey”（基督君王万岁）。他们基本上针对卡列斯的政府发动了起义。这就是格雷厄姆·格林的小说《权力与荣耀》（The Power and the Glory）的背景。你一定读过这本书吧，汤姆？不，我没有。
And this is one of the things that really launches this war, called the Cristero War. So the Christians in the rural heartlands of Mexico, they had a slogan, Viva Cristo Rey, Long Live Christ the King. And they basically launch an uprising against Caius's government. This is the context for Graham Greene's novel, The Power and the Glory. You must have read that, Tom. No, I haven't.
哦，当然啦，你没读过。你在格雷厄姆·格林身上有盲区。我读过《布赖顿硬糖》（Brighton Rock），觉得……觉得很糟糕，根本懒得读完。太令人震惊了。我知道……因为托尼——我们戈尔德汉格（Goldhanger）的负责人——他超爱……他总是向我们提……他总是说，我记得第一次见他时，他就说：“你一定要做一期关于格雷厄姆·格林的节目。”我对那句话打了个太极。你当时没说“我觉得很糟糕”吧？不，没有，因为我当时太尊重对方了。你当时很想迎合播客极客的口味，对吧？我确实是这么想的。我说：“当然，我们一定得做，我太喜欢《布赖顿硬糖》了。”不管怎样，抱歉。无论如何，《权力与荣耀》是一本极其精彩的书，讲述了一个神父在这场战争的背景下艰难穿行于墨西哥的故事，在这场战争中，他一旦被抓就会被处决。
Oh, of course you don't have. You've got a blind spot with graham green i read um brighton rock right thought it thought it poor never bothered shocking i know i would take because tony tony our head of goldhanger he loves he loves he's always on us he's always on say he's always say i think the first time i met him he said you must do an episode on graham green i played a dead bat to that you didn't say i thought it bore no i well no because i was far too respectful at that point yeah you really wanted to get the podcasting geek presumably i did i said yes of course we must i love brighton rock absolutely anyway sorry anyway the power of the glory is a brilliant book about this priest kind of trudging across Mexico in the context of this war in which basically if he's caught, he'll be killed.
而且有10万人在那场战争中丧生。这可不是什么小打小闹。这不是马岛战争。你知道，这是一件惊天动地的大事。我对20世纪墨西哥历史的了解不是很好。好吧。但我确实有一种感觉，那些战争可绝非小打小闹。完全不是。
And 100,000 people were killed in this war. This is not some piff. This isn't the Falklands. You know, this is a massive deal. My knowledge of 20th century Mexican history isn't great. Right. But the sense I do have is that the wars were not piffling. No, not at all.
而且这对教会有着巨大的冲击。所以在1920年代，墨西哥大约有5000名神父；到了1934年，为1500万人口服务的神父只剩下334人。到1935年，墨西哥的17个州里甚至连一个神父都没有了。我完全不知道这一点。所以你可以想象那种反教权主义者与西班牙内战的情景——这正是那种情况。不过现在有多少神父？更多了，他们回来了。我想他们已经回来了，对吧？有点像加拿大的海狸！就像加拿大的海狸，一度濒临灭绝，现在又卷土重来。这是我们《历史的其余部分》世界杯剧集的又一个主题。所以墨西哥的天主教徒和海狸有着某种相似的……神父，没有神父，因为毫无疑问，民众依然保持着天主教信仰。
And it has a massive effect on the church. So in the 1920s, there had been about 5,000 priests in Mexico. By 1934, there are only 334 serving 15 million people. By 1935, 17 of the states of Mexico have no priest in them at all i had no idea so that sort of you think of the anti-clericals and the spanish civil war this is that but how many are there now more many they've come back i think they've come back yes exactly a bit like the beavers in canada right so the beavers in canada verge of extinction but now coming back the theme of another of our Rest is History
是的，他们确实保持着。但用美国历史学家唐纳德·马布里（Donald Mabry）的话来说，他指出：到1940年，
World Cup episodes. So Mexican Catholics and beavers very kind of... Priests, no priests, because presumably the people do stay Catholic. Yes, they do. But to quote the American historian Donald Mabry, he says, by 1940
墨西哥的教会已经不具备任何法人实体、没有任何房地产、没有学校、没有修道院、没有女修道院、没有外国神父、没有在公众或法庭上为自己辩护的权利。其神职人员被禁止穿着神职服装、禁止投票、禁止举行公开仪式或参与政治。这太不可思议了吧？这让托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）看起来简直可以说是慈悲为怀了。是的，确实如此。所以他们用对本土印记的崇拜取代了这一切。
the church in Mexico had no corporate existence, no real estate, no schools, no monasteries, no convents, no foreign priests, no right to defend itself publicly or in the courts. Its clergy were forbidden to wear clerical garb, to vote, to celebrate public ceremonies, or to engage in politics. That's extraordinary, isn't it? That makes Thomas Cromwell look positively kindly. Yeah, it does. So what they replaced that with is this cult of the indigenous.
这就是迭戈·里维拉、弗里达·卡洛以及所有这些创作的由来。其中最著名的例子就是他们试图摆脱——嗯，我刚才在中场休息前说的是圣诞老人，但他们当时会说“圣诞老人”（Santa Claus），因为他们认为圣诞老人是洋基帝国主义。你知道他们试图用谁来取代他吗，汤姆？奇韦·托特克（Xipe Totec）。离那不远。剥皮之神（The Flayed One）。他不是诸神世界杯的参赛选手吗？
And that's where you get Diego Rivera, Frida Kahlo, and all this kind of stuff. And the most famous example of that is their attempt to get rid of, well, I said Father Christmas before the break, but they would have said Santa Claus because they see Santa Claus. It's Yankee. Yankee imperialism. And do you know who they tried to replace him with, Tom? Chippy Totec. Not far off. The Flayed one. The Lord of the Flayed. Who was in the World Cup of Gods, wasn't he?
在第一轮就惨遭淘汰了。因为他总是穿着被他剥皮致死的人的皮到处走动。他们试图用一个同样……圣诞节啊，把那个带进烟囱里。一个同样……一个同样不靠谱的向小孩子们赠送礼物的使者来取代他。
Crashed out in the first round. Because he goes around wearing the skins of people he's flayed to death. They tried to replace him with perhaps an equally Christmas. Have that come down the chimney. An equally... An equally implausible purveyor of gifts to small children.
羽蛇神（Quetzalcoatl）。是的，传说中科尔特斯被误认为的那位神，虽然实际上并非如此。但确实不是，没错。所以到了这个时候，卡列斯已经将权力交给了他的继任者，一个名叫拉萨罗·卡德纳斯（Lázaro Cárdenas）的人。卡德纳斯的政府对这个想法非常热衷，他们基本上说：如果我们摆脱了圣诞老人，我们不需要……
Quetzalcoatl, the feathered serpent. Yes, who was... Cortez is traditionally said to have been mistaken for, but wasn't. But wasn't, exactly. So by this point caius had given way to his successor who was a guy called um lazaro cardenas and cardenas his administration was very keen on the idea they said basically if we get rid of santa claus we don't
羽蛇神魁茨尔科亚特尔。是的，传说中科尔特斯曾被误认为是羽蛇神，但实际上并非如此。确实不是。所以到这个时候，卡里亚斯已经退位，他的继任者是一个叫拉萨罗·卡德纳斯的人，卡德纳斯的政府对这个想法非常热衷，他们基本上说，如果我们摆脱圣诞老人，我们就不会
like coca-cola we don't like you know american influence if we get rid of santa claus we place him with quetzalcoatl then that that would teach children about Mexican history and return us to our pre-colonial traditions. So unbelievably, in December 1930, in the National, you mentioned Mexican stadiums, in the National Stadium in Mexico City. So was that at the Estadio Azteca that we mentioned at the start of the show? No, sadly, Tom, it would be a beautiful link if it had been at the Azteca Stadium. But it wasn't because that wasn't built until the 1960s. So it was a national stadium, it was called, in Mexico City. So they build a pyramid inside the national stadium,
就像我们不喜欢可口可乐一样，你知道的，美国的影响。如果我们摆脱圣诞老人，把他换成克察尔科亚特尔，那么这就能教导孩子们墨西哥的历史，并让我们回归前殖民地时期的传统。所以难以置信的是，在1930年12月，在国家体育场——你提到了墨西哥的体育场，在墨西哥城的国家体育场。那么，这就是我们在节目开始时提到的阿兹特克体育场吗？不，遗憾的是，汤姆，如果当时是在阿兹特克体育场，那将是一个美丽的联结。但事实并非如此，因为那个体育场直到20世纪60年代才建成。所以那是一个被称为国家体育场的体育场，在墨西哥市。他们在国家体育场内部建造了一座金字塔，
and then they basically encourage all the children of the city to assemble in the stadium. And at the top of the pyramid, a man dressed as the Feathered Serpent distributes presents to them. So it would be like building kind of a replica of Stonehenge in Wembley. In Wembley. And a man and a druid. Sacrifices someone.
然后他们基本上鼓励城市里的所有儿童在体育场里集会。在金字塔的顶部，一个扮成羽蛇神的人向他们分发礼物。所以这就像是在温布利建造了一个巨石阵的复制品。在温布利。而且有一个人和一个德鲁伊。献祭某人。
Yeah, or somebody dressed as Woden. Amazingly, this didn't take off. People were too loyal to Santa Claus. So it didn't work. But the weird thing is actually, so this then led me down, I'm going to put inverted commas around the words research. I think it's fair to say
是的，或者有人打扮成沃顿。令人惊奇的是，这并没有流行起来。人们对圣诞老人的忠诚度太高了。所以它没有成功。但奇怪的事情实际上是，这随后引导我走入，我要给“研究”这个词加上引号。我觉得这样说很公平，
because I'm not an expert. People may have worked out already I'm not a great expert in Mexican history. But it led me down something of a rabbit hole because there is a strange subset of history
因为我不是专家。人们可能已经发现我并不是墨西哥历史的超级专家。但这把我带入了一个有点像兔子洞的境地，因为存在着一小群奇怪的历史学家，
about people who think that Quetzalcoatl was somebody else. So for example, the Mormons believe that he was Jesus. Yes. So the third Mormon president, John Taylor in the 1880s, said that we can come to no other conclusion other than that Quetzalcoatl and Jesus are the same being.
他们认为克察尔科亚特尔是另一个人。例如，摩门教徒认为他是耶稣。是的。因此，第三任摩门教总统约翰·泰勒在19世纪80年代说过，我们只能得出这样一个结论：克察尔科亚特尔和耶稣是同一个存在。
Because both were feathered serpents. But the history of the former has been handed down to us through an impure source, which has disfigured and perverted the original incidents and teachings of the savior's life and ministry. D.H. Lawrence, he was a great enthusiast for all this kind of business. So I know you're down on green.
因为两者都是羽蛇。但前者的历史是通过不纯正的源头传给我们的，这扭曲并曲解了救世主生平和事工的最初事件和教导。D·H·劳伦斯，他是所有这类事情的狂热爱好者。所以我知道你讨厌绿色。
Are you also down on Lawrence? Yes, down on Lawrence too. I had to do the rainbow for a level. Didn't like it. Gibberish. I have to be honest with you. I'm not a massive D.H.
你也讨厌劳伦斯吗？是的，我也讨厌劳伦斯。我为了A-level考试不得不读《虹》。不喜欢。胡言乱语。我得对你实话实说。我不是一个非常狂热的D·H·
Lawrence person. I just think there's so much it's so overwritten so self-indulgent and there's just excessive uses of the word loins yes which he uses multiple times a page and all that yeah yeah it's just too much isn't it anyway this has nothing to do with there the dead but in he went to mexico he wrote his book the plumed serpent and he has this sort of weird it's this weird fantasy in which a weird fantasy in dh lawrence yes surely not in which the catholic church it's kind of a preview of the cristeria war actually in which the catholic church is outlawed in mexico and replaced by the worship of quetzalcoatl which completely takes over this is his sort of for a
劳伦斯迷。我只是觉得里面有太多东西，文字太冗长，太自我放纵了，而且对“腰部”这个词的使用频率过高，是的，他每页都要用好多次，诸如此类，是的，是的，实在是太多了，对吧？总之，这和死者毫无关系，但在他去了墨西哥之后，他写了《羽蛇》这本书，他有这样一种奇怪的，这是一种奇怪的幻想，在D·H·劳伦斯的作品中，是的，当然有，在这个幻想中，天主教会在墨西哥被取缔，取而代之的是对克察尔科亚特尔的崇拜，这完全接管了一切，这可以说是他的一种……
man who basically spent the first years of his life hanging around pubs in mining villages in North Hampshire or whatever, this was all a bit much. Anyway, listen, the Cardenas period, so Lázaro Cardenas, the president, it's under him that they really, really push the Day of the Dead. And in fact, that woman I mentioned earlier from the Institute of Anth dead and in fact that woman i mentioned earlier from the institute of anthropology in mexico city elsa malvido she says the altars in people's homes all that stuff that you would think is a you know a survival of an ancient past all this stuff is basically invented in the 1930s so dominic that's really interesting because it's around the same time that the theories that
对于一个基本上把生命的前几年都花在汉普郡北部矿区酒吧里闲逛的人来说，这一切有点太夸张了。总之，听着，卡德纳斯时期，也就是拉萨罗·卡德纳斯总统在任期间，正是在他的领导下，他们才真正、真正大力推崇亡灵节。事实上，我之前提到的那位来自墨西哥城人类学研究所的女性，埃尔萨·马尔维多，她说人们家里的祭坛，所有那些你认为是古代流传下来的东西，所有这些基本上都是在20世纪30年代发明的。所以多米尼克，这真的很有趣，因为这大约与那些理论出现的时间相同，即
christian festivals are pagan festivals in reality start to become popular. And it reflects an assumption that this is how states can operate. It is clearly an entirely 20th century one. In an age when the state is powerful. Yes. So the idea that a Christianized Roman empire would bother Christianizing, I don't know, Saturnalia or whatever yeah that they would they would have the power and the kind of conceptual framework to do that yeah and it probably is that so that it that is they're probably drawing on you know the example of what's going on in mexico and well i'm sure people the 1920s and 30s is an age when people are amounting spectacular
基督教节日实际上是异教节日的观点开始流行起来。这反映了一种假设，即这就是国家运作的方式。这显然完全是20世纪的产物。在一个国家强大的时代。是的。所以，一个基督教化的罗马帝国会费心去将萨图尔纳利亚或其他什么节日基督教化，这种想法——是的，他们拥有这样做的权力和某种概念框架，是的，这可能就是——所以，这很可能是他们在借鉴墨西哥发生的事情的例子，而且我相信人们在20世纪20年代和30年代是一个人们正在举办壮观的
kind of public rituals, aren't they? I mean, you just think about Hitler and his rallies. People are mounting these rituals that are deliberate kind of blends of modern and ancient. And it's easy to kind of then project that back and think that people have always been doing this. So the fact that it is in the 1930s and it's at an age of anti-Catholicism, that explains, I think, why you get the playing up of so many of the non-Catholic, non-obviously Catholic elements. The playing up of the skulls, the playing up of all this, the indigenous nature of it.
那种公开仪式的时代，不是吗？我的意思是，你想想希特勒和他的集会。人们正在举行这些刻意将现代与古代融合的仪式。人们很容易把这种现象投射到过去，认为人们一直都在这样做。因此，它发生在20世纪30年代，发生在一个反天主教的时代，我认为这解释了为什么你会看到如此多的非天主教、显然非天主教的元素被大肆渲染。头骨的展示，所有这一切的展示，其本土性质的展示。
But obviously, it's still fundamentally, I mean, the dates and the concern with the afterlife. Yeah. It's entirely Christian. Yeah, it is. I think that's fair to say. I think that is fair to say. I think basically what you would say, if you were stepping right back from it is you would say it's a medieval spanish christian dressed dressed up in feathers that's been dressed up in 20th century
但很显然，它本质上依然——我是说，日期和对来世的关注。是的。它完全是基督教的。是的，确实如此。我认为这样说很公平。我想这绝对是公正的评价。我想你基本上会说，如果你从宏观角度来看，你会说这是一个中世纪的西班牙基督徒，穿着，穿着羽毛衣服，被装扮成20世纪的
in a 20th century green feathers the green feathers of quetzalcoatl exactly but let's go back end by going right back to where we started, which was the James Bond. So in the film Spectre, Bond is dressed in this fantastic outfit. He has a top hat. He has the skull and he's got this sort of girlfriend who she's also incredibly beautiful, but she has this sort of, it would amaze you to hear that Tom.
20世纪的绿色羽毛，克察尔科亚特尔的绿色羽毛，完全是这样。但让我们回到原点，回到我们开始的地方，也就是詹姆斯·邦德。所以在电影《幽灵党》中，邦德穿着这套奇妙的服装。他戴着一顶礼帽。他带着骷髅头，还有一个女朋友，她也美得不可方物，但她有这种，你听到这个可能会觉得很惊讶，汤姆。
She has this sort of skull mask and everybody has this sort of skull mask. And that now that costume, that is 19th century because actually you will see there that question first of all you will see it in diego rivera's one of in one of his murals that you were talking about so a mural called the dream of a sunday afternoon at alameda central park it's a it's a sort of satire of the world before the Mexican Revolution. So rich people are kind of promenading in the park, but on one they're having a fine old time but actually there's death in their souls that's key part of ribera's mural but he actually got that idea everything has everything you know there's layers upon layers he got that idea from a 19th century cartoon so by a guy called jose guadalupe posada who was writing in the mid-19th century who filled his car he was critical of the 19th century regime of the dictator at the time
她戴着这种骷髅面具，每个人都戴着这种骷髅面具。而现在那套服装，那是19世纪的，因为实际上你会看到，首先你会看到它出现在迭戈·里维拉的一幅壁画中，也就是你刚才谈到的其中一幅壁画，一幅名为《阿拉米达中央公园星期日下午的梦》的壁画。这是对墨西哥革命前世界的一种讽刺。所以有钱人在公园里漫步，但一方面他们过得很愉快，但实际上他们的灵魂中存在着死亡，这是里维拉壁画的关键部分。但他实际上从一幅19世纪的漫画中获得了这个灵感——每件事都有，你知道的，层层叠叠的灵感——他从一个名叫何塞·瓜达卢佩·波萨达的19世纪中期作家的作品中得到了这个灵感，波萨达的作品充满了，他对当时的独裁者波菲里奥·迪亚兹的19世纪政权持批评态度，
porfirio diaz and he filled his stuff with skulls and skeletons and his most famous character was called la calavera garbancera who which is a upper class woman in a very flowery kind of French style hat. The Frenchness is obviously bad. Yes. For reasons to do with the last emperor of Mexico that we did that wonderful episode on. French, French poor behavior in Mexico in the 19th century.
波菲里奥·迪亚兹，他的作品中充满了头骨和骷髅，他最著名的角色被称为加尔巴塞拉骷髅头，这是一个穿着非常华丽的法式风格帽子的上流社会女性。这种法式风格显然是不好的。是的。这与我们做过的那期精彩节目的墨西哥最后一位皇帝有关。19世纪法国人在墨西哥表现出的糟糕行为。
She's called, now this woman today, she's called, she's known in Mexico as Katrina. She's incredibly elegant and all this, but her face is a skull. And you know historians now say well this cartoonist he was obviously influenced by the idea of the dance of death you know the dance of the dead from the sort of medieval and renaissance dancing macabre interestingly he's also mocking the 19th
她被称为，现在这个女人今天被称为，在墨西哥她被称为卡特里娜。她极其优雅，诸如此类，但她的脸是一个骷髅。你知道现在历史学家说，这个漫画家显然受到了死之舞概念的影响，你知道的，来自中世纪和文艺复兴时期的死亡之舞。有趣的是，他还在嘲笑19世纪
century mexican fashion at the time which was for posh women to deny their mexicanness to make themselves look european to whiten their faces so they look like skulls so they look like skulls so it's so it's the day of the dead is ultimately uh an anti-french yeah like all good like all good traditions so in other words that opening scene inspector james bond is dressed as ultimately a 19th century political cartoon of an aristocratic mexican woman love it um people the people inspector who are out there in the um in the streets they are enjoying a procession that doesn't exist in reality and never had existed and insofar as there are authentic elements in that scene they're not
当时墨西哥上流社会的时尚，即有钱的女性否认自己的墨西哥身份，试图让自己看起来像欧洲人，把脸涂白，这样她们看起来就像骷髅，这样她们看起来就像骷髅。所以亡灵节最终是一个反法兰西的节日——是的，就像所有优秀的传统一样。换句话说，在《幽灵党》的那个开场场景中，詹姆斯·邦德最终被装扮成了一个19世纪墨西哥贵族女性的政治讽刺漫画。太棒了。呃，那些在街上的《幽灵党》中的人们，他们正在享受一场现实中并不存在也从未存在过的游行。就该场景中存在真实的元素而言，它们并非
indigenous they're actually medieval Christian, and they acquired their current flavor from the kind of anti-clericalism of the late 19th and early 20th century. But there's a huge sort of twist to all this. So most people, when they saw that film, actually Spectre was not a great James Bond film, but a lot of people said the best thing about it was that opening scene, the pre-credit sequence with Bond in Mexico.
本土的，实际上是中世纪基督教的，它们从19世纪末和20世纪初的反教权主义中获得了当前的风味。但这一切背后有一个巨大的转折。所以大多数人在看到那部电影时，实际上《幽灵党》并不是一部伟大的詹姆斯·邦德电影，但很多人说其中最好的部分是开场场景，也就是邦德在墨西哥的演职员表前的序列。
And because of the interest in it, the Mexican government decided that they would do that parade after all. So the year after it came out, they launched the first Dia de Muertos parade in the center of Mexico City, which was attended by a quarter of a million people. And they have
由于人们对它的兴趣，墨西哥政府决定无论如何也要举办那场游行。所以在电影上映的第二年，他们在墨西哥城中心推出了第一场亡灵节游行，有四分之一万人参加。从那以后，他们
been doing Day of the Dead parades in Mexico City ever since. That is so genius. And in a thousand years' time, when scholars are trying to tease out the origins of this ancient Aztec procession through
一直在墨西哥城举办亡灵节游行。这太天才了。在千年之后，当学者们试图理清这场穿越墨西哥城核心的古老阿兹特克游行的起源时，
the heart of Mexico City. By an Aztec novelist called Ian Fleming. The mystery. Yes, it will take so much effort to tease out the truth. Donny, that was brilliant. Muchas gracias. Yes, that's de nada, Tom. You're very welcome.
由一个名叫伊恩·弗莱明的阿兹特克小说家创作。这个谜团。是的，理清真相需要付出如此多的努力。多尼，这太精彩了。非常感谢。是的，不用谢，汤姆。不客气。
So we've got all kinds of treats coming up on The Rest is History. The podcasting equivalent of sugar skulls and sweet breads. Haven't we, Tom? Yeah. We invent all our own traditions on the show. Uh, and we will,
所以接下来我们在《历史其余部分》节目中还有各种各样的精彩内容。播客界的糖骷髅和甜面包。对吧，汤姆？是的。我们在节目中发明了我们自己的所有传统。呃，我们将在
um, look forward to seeing you next time. Bye. Bye. Hasta luego. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
嗯，期待下次再见。再见。再见。回头见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》，这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦以及我们的问答环节的固定栏目。
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。